[Music]
welcome back to a very special worth it
holiday special par 3 today I'm worth it
Andrew and I are hosting a potluck but
before that we're heading over to a
butcher shop to pick up our centerpiece
roast which Stephen and I will actually
be cooking ourselves a first for worth
it I am honestly very worried about that
say hi my name is Eddie shin we're at a
cut above butcher shop and today we will
be doing a dry ADEs prime rib roast we
specialize in full animal butchering so
we bring in the whole pay the whole beef
the legs we make them sandwiches we
roast them off nose-to-tail we use
everything what is the prime rib cut
prime rib cut is one of the loin cuts
which is the center of the cattle
everything else tends to be a little
tougher and you have to treat it
differently but those are the most
tender and little otherwise what happens
through the dry aging process is that
enzymes start to break down the fibers
of the beef the water evaporates so
intensifies the flavor on a steak you
can literally almost stick your finger
through the state the fat has a kind of
blue cheesy nutty taste to it so the
taste profile is quite so what I'll be
for you guys is what we call cradling
when we detach the rib and then tie it
back on so once you finish roasting all
you have to do is cut twine off and then
the ribs just pop off oh nice
it's ready this life are there any
things we should watch out for roasting
this versus a cut that hasn't been
dry-aged it will cook a little bit
faster don't overcook it very simple we
probably can't mess it up probably not I
saw you guys also serve sandwiches here
yes you have a favor one you recommend
we try respite for a bit very good so
the burger is Glen ribeye brisket and
short rib but we put some nice
caramelized onions Point Reyes blue
cheese on top with russian dressing
lettuce tomato and a brioche bun so this
is a little mouth teaser the beef that
we're gonna be having later
look at that cross-section yeah this is
incredible oh it's so beautiful here
oh my oh my mmm this is inspiring me for
the bottle up we got to get the meat to
taste like this
moist juicy medium-rare you know how
they say don't go to a grocery store if
you're hungry go to this butcher shop
hungry finish burger and those seasons
of meat
[Music]
okay today is the big day the great
holiday potluck last night I took this
meat home yes you did and I salted it
and peppered it and I left it in my
fridge uncovered so that the outside
could dry and then I brought it here
we're gonna be using this recipe and
methodology of cooking it that andrew
has decided on I am just his sous chef
today boom sous chef you think you're a
sous chef in my kitchen
yeah no no no no no no line cook dish
bucket boy that's fine actually there it
is four ribs and look at this oh it's
already like meat taffy whoa
chef Oh Nikki take it to the promised
land what's going on I'm gonna see her
every exposed surface that I can I don't
like when you a sunbathing does that
turn a little bit to the side you got to
get an even tan oh well that's great so
this is actually something I've never
cooked before but my family and had like
every holiday of my life for a family
holiday meal we never do the big piece
of meat we do hotpot okay I think I'm
gonna stop cooking this now oh I'm gonna
stick this thermometer in here oven time
okay we do not axe it we're watching out
for about a hundred seventeen degrees
internal temp it's not an exact time so
I think we should just check it in a
couple of hours hey Google set a
reminder to check the meat around 1:00
p.m.
all right I'll remind you at 1:00 p.m.
one of our guests is arriving early to
mix up his very special yes Kwasi uh and
now we wait Sudan hello crazy
bunch wouldn't you bring this is punch
to crema a big traditional Christmas
drink that my family makes all the time
as a young man I couldn't drink it
because it has rum in it it has
condensed milk nutmeg evaporated milk
possessed of lime in it and the most
important ingredient and rum but some
the West Indian version of eggnog
but if eggnog was better that's not bad
oh man that's not bad at all it's milk
alcohol mm-hmm and it's a little bit why
daddy likes drink and do it okay all
right daddy you guys you can make
yourself comfortable we got to check the
meat the rest of the guests will be here
in a second wait this is a party yeah
it's not just us drinking Oh drinking
this much should we milk oh I wonder the
mints
you want to do these yeah too bad
yes really used to human oh yeah okay so
now I have seven we're just gonna build
a pen smash this on here easy now we
wait for our guests to arrive hello
welcome to the potluck we have the
appetizers in front of us which we can
thank you no no Brendan my ADA four so
this is kanji cassia and it's a really
common presidents name you can have it
with anything so we have cut opt within
guava jam and so I made some kmb samosas
so it takes twice beating pastry and
make sure you like give a generous
squeeze of lime on it it takes it to a
whole nother level
yeah this is hot and crispy maybe did I
always liked the food triangle I have to
make a little hole and then I just a job
filter is right now the rice Hexe Trude
I'm going to the cream cheese that's
good
don't you want just laying that just
like a little little cheese sleeping bag
I bought Caribbean punch de creme
it has rum in it boys he's had some
punch so far feeling it yeah was a three
it's a real mentally a flavor you would
think it would kind of wash each other
out but I actually think they accentuate
each other quite nicely that could be
this guy's worth it's I'm coming for
your job man I think there's a whole
bottle of rum in that bowl of punch
[Music]
prime rib yeah oh that smell oh oh it's
ready to be sliced by yours truly Steven
Lim and we'll save this in sweet Vince
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah it's a big slap this
license for crazy how thin can you make
it because I want it I want it like
paper thin
nice yeah I'm gonna cut off the big
piece of bedroom
Shane no a drift up me yeah you're in
for a treat
alright we'll get the rest of this
sliced up and we'll meet you guys at the
table ready bump bump bump bump bump
here comes the meat here comes the meat
here comes the meaty Moody
oh yeah the beef is really well cooked
they're just really delicious fantastic
oh yeah definitely the juiciest piece of
beef I've ever tasted well it's
perfectly edible Andrew Wow okay buddy
it's good it's good like a bit slow and
low what is that
between the roast and the potatoes oh
the cookie spicy rice cake that's like
the pumpkin spice latte of Korean Street
food Wow picked it up from restaurant I
should need you in topside agenda this
rice cake Wow it's a bit spicy if you're
not into spicy food it's a very
satisfying texture it's time to feed
that somebody feed Adam here Adam come
over here I'll hook you up
oh wait phones you can easily
that's--you're that mix of cultures
[Music]
who's ready for dessert
these pies are from the pie hole it's
the best pie place in all the world
it's a sponsored by the hi no but my
life is here we have apple chocolate
silk pomegranate Earl Grey and pecan
Earl Grey is so good oh my god who's
eating the chocolate pomegranate I am
the pomegranates mixing with the
chocolate you get a little explosion in
there create as a dessert stop what is
your favorite pie I use example usually
pies like cavada meets pie crust but has
crumble right so it's uh it's different
I mean like it's a good way kind of like
a bit unconventional for where you would
expect for a traditional vice they're
unique you know after trying the Earl
Grey is clearly best the Queen at the
table of the pies this is like the bad
boy of the table oh yeah it's the core
gesture of mouths off every once in a
while all right for the final
showstopper guys Rhea is in town oh yeah
you shouldn't have this it's
croquembouche which is creampuff Tower I
made it at Russian Roulette so two of
them has wasabi net
who wants to go first alright when is
one had time I'll go first
cheers yeah cheers good luck buck I
really hope that's not mine because I
already had this Shane what's your
strategy I'm gonna put the whole thing
in money put it all in your mouth all or
nothing you want to do this at the same
time you bet I do
okay are you ready to dance big boy yeah
I'm ready to death all right here we go
three two one
boy you ready for the croquembouche this
has been a worth it all day special
thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yes